okay I want to deal now with something
that many of you and I have been
noticing about coronavirus lately cases
have exploded I mean just insane numbers
of cases and it's specifically in some
states and not in others
but the death numbers have not been high
for now that's a good thing I don't want
anybody catching coronavirus I don't
want anybody dying from coronavirus but
the question is based on the case
numbers we would expect deaths to be
higher in some of these states
especially ones where we're learning
that the IC user maxed out so what's
going on there now as a reminder I have
no political perspective here my
ideology on the virus is health it just
so happens the president we have has
failed miserably on coronavirus but I
want to find the real explanation and I
want to find the truth so here's a few
ideas that have been proposed about why
there have been so many cases but
relatively fewer deaths than we were
seeing a few months ago okay one
possibility that's been proposed is that
we are getting better at treating
coronavirus in other words if you get
sick enough to go into the hospital
doctors are now better at treating
because we have three months of
experience and thus you would expect the
death rate to be lower in fact there is
a study called decreased in hospital
mortality in patients with kovat 19
pneumonia and it says that in a lot of
countries fewer people are going to the
hospital and dying and it's a
combination of some hospitals being less
overrun with a better understanding of
how patients should be treated reminder
that's why we lock down when you lock
down you keep the hospitals less full so
the sick people get better care and you
allow time for doctors to learn to
properly treat the disease so hopefully
by the time you get it or your loved one
gets it the medical system is better
equipped to treat very good that's one
possibility
second possibility for why there are a
ton of cases and not as many deaths is
that we just haven't seen the deaths yet
okay
the idea in general is it's like 22 days
from test to death you get a positive
test it's often five days before you end
up in the hospital it's often 17 days
from hospitalization to death so it's
like a 22 day delay between cases and
deaths the current spike started I call
it June 16th if this is the explanation
that we've just haven't seen the deaths
yet we would expect deaths to spike
around June 7th or 8th I hope it doesn't
happen if it is that that's what's going
on the death numbers are going to get
very very ugly very very soon third
possibility for why we have so many
cases and relatively few deaths is that
older folks are better protecting
themselves and staying home and it's the
younger people that are testing positive
younger people much more likely not to
need hospitalization much less likely to
die that would be a possibility we don't
have the full data on that that's really
an empirical question we just don't have
the full data on that so we would have
to see I know that there are some cities
that are saying we are seeing more young
people get it fewer older folks get it
we need to see that at the state level
at the federal level lastly there are
some doctors arguing that the virus is
mutating to be less serious that at this
point the virus has weakened and thus
those who are infected are getting a
less serious version of it than what was
going around in March April and early
May I don't want to say too much about
that because we don't know that to be
the case it's a hypothesis it presumably
could be tested empirically that's not
been done most doctors are saying there
is not actually evidence of that right
now and so I don't want to risk giving
people the wrong idea with something
that has not been demonstrated to be
true still a lot to learn but those are
four of the possibilities for why so far
we are seeing unconscionable spikes in
the number of cases but not yet not yet
seeing and hopefully we won't see
corresponding numbers of deaths let me
know what you think about this